gary kasparov versus nigel short was one  of the biggest chess rivalries of the  90s  gary usually got the better of nigel but  in this position gary had to play the  thematic move  b5 in a thematic match against nigel in  the king's gambit  and this crazy opening did not go well  for gary just  10 short moves later we got to this  position after f5 knight h4 queen g3  nigel's next move makes gary resign can  you  find it that's right or wrong the  winning tactic here is  knight takes e4 taking advantage of  black's  unfortunately placed pieces king's still  in the center so tactics abound  of course if gary had recaptured we're  taking that piece again  and again and after all is said and done  we save our knight with tempo and  take the free rook and so gary resigned  on move 15 one of the shortest losses of  his career